[Music]
[Applause]
steve levy joining us on the program
leaves of course is uh part of the host
duties there with sportscenter espn abc
he's been on site with mark messier
chris celios and uh emily kaplan on ice
reporter leaves joins us now leaves
how's morale in tampa
morning dp uh and that gentleman's right
i meant to say 36 seconds and i said 36
seconds
who hasn't been there right
i'm feeling i'm feeling great uh i don't
think john cooper is uh that happy and
the lightning was all sorts of chaos and
controversy it was one of those uh it
took a really long time to develop it
was a weird game from start to finish
dan
and then at the end you know
nope at first glance i don't think
anybody on the ice knew that puck went
in not even the guy who shot it or the
goalie uh took bowen byram the
defenseman to come all the way from the
blue line to swoop in behind the net to
show everybody
where the puck was actually and then so
then we figure out okay it's over
which was kind of reminiscent remember
patrick kane in 2010 uh the stanley cup
winning goal and kane was the only one
who knew it went in and he's flying down
the ice so and then of course we find
out post game everybody's talking about
the john coop press conference hey you
know with the too many men on the ice so
lots of chaos and um you know talking to
some league people last night afterwards
just my understanding
uh the league sort of admits there was a
mistake they're not going to publicly
say that but really was too many men on
the ice uh it's one of those things it's
a judgment call it's a bad call you
can't challenge it can't do anything
with it after the fact and it's sort of
one of those things you kind of have to
just eat and live with
how often can you call this leaves
you know so the rule changed a few years
ago dan uh i was talking about with mass
shelly it used to be six-seat like i
think it was written into the rule book
like you could be within six feet of the
bench
uh when you were changing the other
player and and so it matters the player
you're changing with it's not just like
the closest guy to the bench
that you when you're coming off the guy
who's replacing you has to be you know
within reason and obviously not
interfering with the play and the puck
not in the area like there are a lot of
variables that go into this and so
you're right too many men on the ice
could be called more often i think the
officials give you some leeway uh but
the player that was actually changing
there was mckinnon who came off for
cadre
and the cartridge scores the goal and
some of the people saying it was 30 feet
away so
um i think i think they missed it it
happens fast uh these guys are massive
the officials have been skating three
four miles themselves on the ice all
night it's chaotic non-stop you're in
overtime pressure's high and all that
stuff
and i think they miss it and i think
there's one of those there's nothing you
can do about it it's not like offside
it's not like goalie interference it's
not like that the puck crossed the line
it's just not one of those things would
you have called it
you know
and again honestly dave we we needed we
were trying to find the puck in the net
first so we got bigger problems right we
got bigger issues there so uh i think
after looking at it but dan i'm talking
about 20 minutes after the fact you know
yeah maybe i would have called it then
but you can't do that that's just that's
not sports even with all the technology
we have uh i i don't i don't think it's
going to call next time either i i just
think that's one of those things we just
missed
how do you think this series plays out
uh i i think it's i think it's colorado
series i think everybody thought that
after after game two i think we were all
surprised what took place in game three
and quite frankly and that's
and that's why if you're an honest tampa
bay lightning fan uh i don't think you
could be that upset you you're bothered
by the goal last night should have been
two any men on the ice that get that but
but probably if they call it back
colorado's score in the next shift you
know what i mean it was uh outside of
the first period i thought tampa bay was
hanging out dear life second period
third period over time
they had a couple of rushes couple
opportunities
but i think colorado's been the better
team and quite frankly the biggest
surprise in the series is the biggest
advantage before the series started was
in goal
and darcy kemper had the one bad game
jared bednar the coach of colorado
elects to bring
bring kemper back and he was terrific
last night and so if they if there's not
the massive advantage in goal for tampa
bay that was their biggest edge to begin
with then it just it just screams
colorado for me kemper is the first
goaltender in nhl history with an
overtime assist
in a stanley cup final game did you know
that liam
uh i knew we had the assist on the goal
i did not know who's
you're talking to a hockey expert here
okay
dan i was talking about you last night
this is so odd i mean it's the small
world we live in right then i get the
call from fritzy uh this morning hey i
want to jump on i am uh uh hotel bar
festivities last night two of your
favorites
so chuck chuck's in the house of course
right because he's everywhere so
barclays with you
oh my god with me in a big way i would
say multiple nights okay
but last night so that was part of the
dan patrick reunion tour and then uh
last night darius pops in darius
yeah and i said to him it's been a long
time he's like yeah i said i haven't
seen you since
dan got us on the stage with berman and
and darius you got us up on the stage
with him and singing the song and then
he he told about the argument you know
he made you famous no you made him
famous you guys have gone back and forth
over that for 30 years or something
anyway there's a damn patrick kind of
night yeah well
you know barkley loves his hockey he
knows his hockey yes
and he's tight with john cooper
oh well he's tight with the commissioner
too because he texted him to say can you
give me some tickets here
and i don't even have gary batman's
phone number charles barkley does i feel
that's wrong every time i see messi i
always think when the rangers won the
cup and i was covering that for
sportscenter and i went to a bar
where they were there with the cup
and they were passing around the cup
and i didn't know what was in it and
messier said if you have to ask you
don't get to drink
so
i don't know what was in it but i drank
it and uh yeah like sure why not
i'm not gonna die it was delicious yeah
so it's uh it's pretty cool for me to be
sitting next to those guys you know
melrose is great and everything and then
you get messy and chilios and it's all
good oh then they start telling stories
most of them you can't tell when you're
on the air
exactly
uh hey great to talk to you buddy
see you soon thank you that's steve levy